[Music]
welcome back everybody that's a massive
hit peekaboo by Korean girl group red
velvet and that video alone Roz has
amassed over 125 million views on
YouTube
yeah their kpop sound is a mix of as you
can tell RB and pop with the mix of
ladies that include joy Jyri irene solji
and wendy now wendy is the only member
who speaks fluent English and she
actually grew up and studied right here
in Toronto yeah and that is where we saw
Carlos where he met the ladies backstage
before their first ever headlining show
in Canada and with the help of a
translator he discovered that yes they
are thrilled about their international
following but even more thrilled about
their proud parents
[Music]
you guys are the first k-pop group to
have four number-one singles on the
Billboard world albums chart
how do your families feel about all the
success you've gotten so far and all
this attention that you guys get um tone
a little girl they're very proud of us
and they actually go tell their friends
and their families and relatives that
over we have a daughter and red velvet
sofa Lillian gets all when they come to
our concert and see all the fans going
on loving us and showing all the support
they actually want to go to every
individual fans and say thank you for
loving our daughters Wendy I know I even
wanted to come back to Canada how does
it feel to be back
well I'm just really happy that I'm back
home and I'm excited and nervous at the
same time because back then when I was
in Canada I would a sweet tooth I used
to be a student
it's reformed here I can't explain how
excited nervous and happy at the same
time it's a very special day for me yeah
have you had old friends reach out and
knowing about your success that you've
had yes actually some of them are coming
today so I'm really nervous okay I'm
sure they're gonna be blown away
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this North American tour is a great next
step for you guys it's gonna give people
an opportunity to see you for the first
time we were very surprised and I
remember myself asking my mom I'm
actually going to North America the
reaction that they're getting from the
North American fans is actually just so
thrilling what can they expect when they
come and see a red-velvet show I just
want them to just come and just enjoy
and just wanna yeah have fun with us
boogie yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
now when you are there any specifically
Canadian things that you would love to
introduce the rest of the group to oh
it's some french fries but they have
gravy over it supposed to them yeah and
uh maple syrup of course of course son I
gave them ready that maple syrup put the
maple tea and the maple chocolate and
the maple cookie this is all maple syrup
stuff delicious so what do you think of
Canada so far pretty cool this is our
first time coming to our Wendy unnies
home country when I first landed here I
almost teared and then burst into crying
we didn't expect it to be this cold but
it was really cold the passion from the
people that were seeing they're very
warm and they're very kind people here
in Canada